-I want to start
by probably just
apologizing in advance
for our crew.
Have they been hassling yo
a great deal?
-No, not at all.
They've been great.
-Alright. That's good,
because they're very,
very excited
that you're here.
Except for Wally,
who's a Mets fan.
-He's a Yankees fan.
-I'm sorry. No.
That's what I meant to say
I didn't boo.
-What?
-I didn't boo.
-That's really big of you,
Wally.
-That's surprising.
-Yeah, a real gentleman, yeah.
-Well, I'm honored and thrille
to be here,
considering I haven't pitche
in a big league game
in like almost two years,
so, I'm just thrilled people
haven't forgotten about me
-Haven't forgotten who you are
We wanted to make sure that,
when you came back,
that people wouldn't be shocked,
so we thought
this would be
a nice way for America
to get used
to your face again.
-Well, I'm glad to be here
-How is rehabbing going?
You mentioned
it's been almost two years
You had Tommy John surgery
and it must be somewhat
of a solitary existence,
being away from the team.
-It's been a long process
and I'm still trying
to kind of figure out
what, exactly, it all mean
over this last 15 months
because, I mean, for the peopl
back home that don't really know
what a Tommy John
UCL reconstruction is,
it takes about 15 months to,
I think, on average,
about 15 months and I recently
had a little setback,
you know, but everybody
seems really encouraged
to the trajectory
that I'm headed.
I don't like putting
timelines on things,
but, hopefully, I'm reaching
all those really
important benchmarks.
-It must've been such
a tricky mental challenge,
as an athlete,
to know, at the beginning,
that it was going to be
at least 15 months.
-Yeah, I mean, I still think
about, to this day,
when I was
in the doctor's office
and I got the news
from the surgeon
that I would need
Tommy John surgery
and it was absolutely
devastating.
But it's all about perceptio
and how you tackle things
in the future
and so I just saw it
as a challenge
and, you know, I'm still
getting challenged, to this day.
-You mentioned that being
a piece of bad news
you remember getting.
I want to ask about the da
you got drafted.
The Major League Baseball draf
is happening right now.
It's a little bit less
of an event, I think,
as the NFL draft, the NBA draft.
One of the reasons, of course,
is so many of you guys
are high schoolers
who none of us have seen before.
You were 18 years old.
You got drafted
in the first round
by the Blue Jays.
What was it like
getting that call?
Were you expecting to be
a first-round draft pick,
at that point?
-I really wasn't, at that time
because,
going into my senior year,
I was pretty content on goin
to Dallas Baptist
for three years
and getting drafted then
and starting my career.
And then I had this
really crazy senior year,
to where I just matured
a lot over the year
and I started throwing
harder and harder
and then I got on a lot
of teams' draft radars
and actually
graduated high school
on the same day
that I got drafted,
so that was
pretty monumental for me.
-That must've been a trip,
for all the other people
graduating high school
to realize.
-It wasn't as cool
of a day for them?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. They're like,
"Well, I was the valedictorian."
"What? Hold on.
It's the Blue Jays."
[ Laughter ]
You were with the
Blue Jays organization
for a couple of years.
Then you end up
at the Mets organization
and your first game, you got
to pitch at Wrigley Field.
I mean, I would imagine
anyone's first game,
no matter where it is,
is pretty memorable,
but were you aware,
in the moment, of like, "Wow
this is a pretty iconic
stadium to make my first start?"
-Yeah. Wrigley's
pretty freaking awesome.
It's just got so much histor
and culture there
and the fans, the Cubs fans,
they're great,
so it was a very memorable place
to make my debut.
Unfortunately, I didn't
get the win, though, so.
-That's alright.
You made up for it.
You've made up for it since.
We also have All-Star Week
Your teammate Pete Alonso is
in the Home Run Derby tonight.
-Yep.
-Are you are you optimisti
on his chances?
-He's definitely my favorite
and I love his confidence
and his swagger.
He's already predetermined tha
he's going to do a repeat, so.
-You are a television fan.
-Mm-hmm.
-You've named your gloves,
over the years,
after some fictional film
and television characters.
-Right.
I haven't done it in a while
-Gotcha.
-but I do have
a Tyrion Lannister.
I had a Jon Snow.
[ Laughter ]
I had a Heisenberg,
because I was really big
into "Breaking Bad"
at the time and I had --
What's the other one?
Heisenberg, Jon Snow...
-Did you have a Rocky?
Was there something
"Rocky"-themed?
-"Walking Dead."
I had a Rick Grimes.
-Oh, you had a Rick Grimes
-Yep, mm-hmm.
And then, do you write
the names in or is it just
how you refer to them?
-No, I have them stitched in
-Oh, you have it stitched in
-Yeah.
Like my Jon Snow glove
was all black, so...
-Yeah, of course.
-And Heisenberg was all blue
of course.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. There you go.
-Tyrion was really small.
-Oh, yeah. I remember.
You had that tiny glove, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You also have made
some TV appearances,
some very memorable
TV appearances.
You were in the show
"Vikings."
-Baseball has given me
a lot of opportunities
to do some really cool things,
like be here.
-There's your episode
of "Vikings."
That was a natural fit
for someone
who is named Syndergaard
and nicknamed "Thor."
-I wish they would've let me
keep the face tattoo.
-[ Laughing ] They didn't
let you keep the tattoos?
-That's how I started shavin
the sides of my head, because,
the end of the season in 2018,
the game ended --
I actually pitched that day --
got on a plane to Ireland
to do that cameo appearanc
and they're like, "Well, what do
you want to do with your hair?
I'm like,
"Well, it's the offseason.
You can do whatever
you want to it,"
so I'm like, "I don't know
Just shave the sides and stuff."
-That's great. See, that's how
TV works for people.
You get mew looks.
It would be great
if you wore this,
instead of a batting helmet.
I think that would be
a good look.
This is you
in "Game of Thrones."
-That's me.
I was a Lannister general.
-Yeah.
-I was a KDR of one to zero.
Got to kill a Dothraki.
-You did?
[ Laughter ]
Horse-bound Dothraki.
-I want to ask about --
I don't think you
ended up very --
your character probably --
-I didn't live very long.
I might have bent a knee
for Daenerys, but.
-That's like one of those guys
who just comes up for a cu
of coffee at the majors.
Like you basically
got one Dothraki
and they sent you back down.
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly.
Back to the minor leagues.
-You also started a book clu
over, I guess it was last year
or during the, I guess, pandemic
was when you started doing thi
and you sort of share online
so your fans can see
which books you're reading
What made you decide
to start doing that?
-Man, there's a lot
of different answers to that
I mean, to be quite honest
when I was in high school,
I made good grades, but I didn't
like reading at all.
Like my parents
and my grandparents
had always like emphasized
strong work ethic,
learning, good character,
just being
the best person you can be
And so it kind of stemmed
from them.
They always encouraged me
to make good grades
and apply myself in school
and the importance of school
but I didn't really see it
until like later,
as I got older and more mature
And COVID happens
or the pandemic started
and then,
everyone had a nice excuse
to just sit home
and watch Netflix.
I mean, everybody gets
into the "Tiger King"
and I even started
that show "Summer House"
and I'm not pleased
to admit that at all,
[ Laughter ]
but I watched all of it in lik
two weeks or so, but.
So, but after I got
through my trash TV phase,
I was like, "Okay,
my mind is getting a littl
stagnant, a little stale,
so I just --
And I was rehabbing, too,
so there wasn't
a whole lot to do
and I turned this house
that I had
into like a recovery/
wellness lounge.
I had an infrared sauna.
I had a cold tub,
or ice plunge.
The backyard
was entirely closed in,
so I spent a lot of time
catching some sun out there,
completely naked, of course.
[ Laughter ]
And then --
-Of course.
-And then I had
[ Laughter ]
a hyperbaric chamber.
And so I had a lot of just tim
where I wasn't doing anything,
so I could just read and I would
just crush books in the sauna,
outside in the cold tub,
and the hyperbaric.
So that was one thing.
I had a lot of time on my hand
and I just --
That happened
for about nine months,
where I just was reading
and me and my two best friends
decided we wanted to start
like our own book club.
That was probably
in November, December.
And then I approached my agenc
and they thought
it was a great idea,
a great way to promote literac
and to engage with my fans
and just kind of show
that I'm not just a one-side
baseball player kind of,
you know.
And one thing I've learned
and it really hit home,
in my most recent book,
Kate Fagan's "All the Colors
came out is like
you take everything that's
materialistic away from us
and, at the end of the day
all we have is love and wisdom
And I think that's something
that you can really get
from reading books.
-I agree with you 100%.
And it's so true,
what you say about --
I always, when people ask me
any advice I have for them
before they go into school
I'm always like,
"You can't believe how littl
time you have to read,
once you finish school."
Like it's the only time
in your life where someone
says like,
"Go back to your room,
read this book,
and that's what we want yo
to do with your time."
And so it's really nice,
I think, as an adult,
when you can find time
to do that.
-Amen.
-I want to ask.
You mentioned the ice bath
When you go into an ice bath
how long do you go into it
-Between three and five minutes.
-Okay.
-It's pretty bad.
-So you have to have
a really short book for that
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-So you go in, but can you read?
-I can't read and do
the cold tub.
That's a bit too much.
-How miserable is it?
Have you gotten better
at the cold tub?
-Well it's miserable,
but the point is
to find comfort in that misery
So like you're doing
other things, like --
I don't know. It's hard
to explain, necessarily,
but like, say, for example
like, you know, like the sayin
"What doesn't kill us
can only make us stronger,
that's kind of like you
stress yourself a little bit
so you can gain this
massive amount of strength
-Gotcha.
-So, when I'm in there,
yeah, it sucks.
I try to find my breath
and try to find comfort
within like the first
30 seconds.
And then I try to like --
I don't want to say
like be happy,
but just try to relax in there
as much as I can and it just
gets easier over time.
-I've always wondered
exactly how long people --
Because even
just watching someone,
I feel my teeth chattering, so
-Yeah, three to five minutes
is like
what I would I would say to do
Like the worst part is
the 30 seconds when you get in
and the 45 minutes
when you get out
[ Laughter ]
to warm yourself back up.
Luckily, I just jump
in the sauna or whatever.
I got a hot tub.
-Yeah, you got a good setup.
One thing, you know, I wan
to apologize for the fact that
shows like mine oftentimes use
the Mets as a punch line,
but one of the things
that's really nice right now
is you guys are
a first-place team
going into the All-Star break.
It would be very nice,
obviously,
and I think we're all optimistic
that you can be a part
of what will, hopefully,
be a second-half push.
But I do want to close
with one last thing.
We have a writer on this sho
who is a huge Mets fan
and we were mentioning
you going to be here today
and he said,
"I've met him twice,
once at the airport
and once at --"
-Oh, that guy.
What is it, Stalker Sal?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, that guy?
-So you remember him?
-Yeah. How could I forget?
Delta Terminal at LaGuardia.
[ Laughter ]
-We were worried because,
when he told us the story,
he said like, "Yeah,
it was really cool
and he was really excited
to meet me,"
and we were like,
"I got to be honest, Sal.
I feel like you might've bee
the creep in the story."
-I couldn't get
away from the guy.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, so,
we're sorry about that.
Thank you, though,
for being here
and best of luck,
both with the rehabilitation
and, hopefully, seeing you i
the second half of the season.
-Thank you for having me.
-That's Noah Syndergaard.
Don't miss
the MLB All-Star Game,
which airs this Tuesday nigh
at 8:00 pm on Fox.